so what was the latest development here
with Riley Gaines so what I wanted to
talk about is is this a story a no
question about it but this kind of stuff
this is an extreme but it happened to
Charles Murray I mean it happens it
happens all the time what's really the
story to me which really the story is
what the university did they said that
they were peaceful protests they offered
them counseling they said transphobia
has no place in the university the
statement if you could pull the
statement up it's an utterly remarkable
it's it's opposite land and this is what
is happening in our universities and
this is why
it's so important to talk about this
it's again what I had mentioned this is
the legitimacy Christ This is a crisis
of legitimacy institutions and this is
contributing to that it's the misuse of
the word phobia that's for sure because
saying that you don't want biological
men to compete in physical sports with
biological females doesn't mean you're
afraid of trans or women's prisons yeah
it's not that you're afraid of it I mean
I'm not afraid I just I'm concerned